I end up posting about six reels a day
which is crazy people are like how do
you post that many reels well three of
them are pretty much new reels which is
still a lot right to make three new
reels a day but the other two to three
they're just strictly like content ads
where we're just recycling them over and
over again I probably have 60 of them
between all my different companies
because I have different keywords I'll
be like DM me flip if you this is for
somebody who wants to learn how to
invest in real estate I'll say DME tax
if you want to go work with true books
DME Ecom if you want to go get an Amazon
automation store I have them set up for
every single company I have